the first thing we should do is is is
really stay calm they usually find out
from the first of all they usually find
out that they've got breast cancer most
often through a radiologist or the
radiologist will call the primary care
physician and give the news to him or
her to forward on to the patient so you
really need to start to you know if
you're panicked I mean it feels like
someone kicked you in the stomach when
you hear Lee I'm sorry to tell you this
but your tumor is malignant the next
step is to really see a breast surgeon
and the breast surgeon is the person
that's going to determine whether your
tumor needs surgery first or whether it
needs to have chemotherapy first before
the tumors removed or radiation it'll
the surgeon determines this you know
what the treatment process what
direction you're going to go in so I
always say take a deep breath find any
honestly I found any breast surgeon just
to answer questions I found out on a
Friday and it was the friday of Columbus
Day weekend to find a surgeon that was
willing and able to meet us on a Monday
most of them had the day off you know go
this the weekend without knowing
anything was just really frightening i
can say that everybody's breast cancer
or any kind of cancer tumor is is a very
individual and you can't go on the
internet start researching before you
know exactly what the tumor entails
there's a lot of detail information that
doctors won't know until even after the
surgery so to panic and go into reading
the what-ifs before you know exactly
what your tumor detail is is is really
over its it's a bad idea so I tell
people to stay calm call their insurance
carrier that's the first thing to do
find out if what your insurance can
cover find out how to find doctors that
are covered
in your insurance so you don't have to
have excessive medical bills that's
really important and also once you call
the insurance carrier ask if there's a
person that you can speak with on an
ongoing basis one person who can be sort
of an account manager so you don't have
to talk to new people every single time
you pick up the call that's important
too because you need that partner in the
insurance area to answer questions I
like to tell people not to panic about
any potential financial burdens because
if they have insurance or little
insurance the first thing they need to
know is what's covered if they have
little insurance or no insurance there
are resources out there for patients to
help them manage their medical bills
whether they help them negotiate lower
prices whether they go to the
pharmaceuticals directly and ask for
free chemotherapy which can be provided
based on their income there are
absolutely resources to help those
patients and I I have a list of those
resources on my website one of the major
organizations that I like to tell
patients about if there's a issue with
their medical bills is to go to the
patient advocacy foundation and they're
based in Washington DC they have an 800
number they have a website and they have
people there who can help people with
anyone with a language barrier or
cultural barriers financial barriers so
if you're you know if you speak Spanish
there's an there is someone there to
help them in their own language and help
them manage and cope emotionally and
financially to get them the help they
need the biggest unfortunate situation
is that the highest rate of deaths are
with people with language and cultural
and financial barriers and the medical
community advocacy the government ever
buddy is aware of this issue and doing
everything they can to provide
information and reach out to this
demographic to make sure that their
service their needs are covered and to
let them know that they don't need to go
home it's not a death sentence many
people of that demographic think that
cancer is a death sentence or they don't
want to burden their family with the
financial hardship of caring for cancer
and so you know cancer 101 and all other
major advocacy groups and cancer centers
alike are really trying to break that
barrier and let them know that there are
there's help out there for them we
actually have a list of questions that
were provided to us by ASCO the American
Society of Clinical Oncology I would
always recommend that people who have
been a diagnosed with cancer make sure
that they go to those web to our website
or to cancer net and get those questions
so that there are prepared to ask the
doctor anything regarding the tumor size
what to expect what kind of surgery
whether it's a lumpectomy or mastectomy
and why would they recommend one over
the other to discuss hereditary issues
who in the family has had breast cancer
in the past because that is a big
decision to understand and know what
your history as some people don't know
whether because they've been adopted or
because their family is strange they
don't know the family history but it is
important to gather as much information
and bring that information with you so
that the doctor can assess if you have
history in the family that only
magnifies or I wouldn't say magnifies it
only provides the doctor with more
information to determine what type of
surgery or treatment they would
recommend
first of all you have a lot of
well-wishers a lot of friends and family
that want to help you and sometimes it's
a little too much and a little
overbearing I mean the phone rang off
the hook and you don't feel well
returning this phone call so I think
just letting everybody know in advance
don't be hurt or be insulted that I'm
not calling you back I just don't have
the energy but usually the best way to
go about it is to have one friends sort
of be the command post and help manage
on your day-to-day needs I may recommend
having one person always go with you to
doctors appointments because you're not
going to be able to ask the right
questions you won't listen very well
because you're thinking about the last
thing the doctor just said to you so to
make sure that somebody with a clear
head can ask the questions and take
notes it's very important if you don't
have someone to go with you ask if a
nurse can come in and take notes for you
or often doctors will even let you bring
in a tape recorder so you can listen
back to the questions that you might
have on the listen to the answers that
the doctors have I recommend giving
allowing yourself plenty of sleep this
is your time to you know make do
anything and everything you need to make
yourself feel good don't feel obligated
to be part of an event or or you know a
birthday party if you're not feeling up
to it don't go people will understand do
as much as you can let people at the
office you know depending on the type of
work or job you have try and lay out a
plan that you can either leave early
every day or help somebody have somebody
in the office you know partner with you
to take some of the burden off of your
job I made the mistake of you know
trying to take on too much working all
the way through and didn't felt guilty
asking anybody for help quite frankly
and that was a mistake I should have
asked for help I should have left every
day three o'clock whether I was tired
not to take care of myself and I worked
all the way through until I literally
would collapse and head hump and sleep
all weekend so I don't recommend that at
all